hey everybody it is Monday again hope
everybody had a good weekend or as may
be now makes more sense to say a weekend
I am here I still have not shaved my
beard and we are here for another Donald
Trump Whitehouse coronavirus press
briefing I had a couple of interesting
conversations over the weekend actually
just about really how I should be
covering these and as you all know you
know I've had my reservations before
because they are so little and such
locusts Azure loci of propaganda but at
the same time this is sometimes the
first place where new policy is
announced so going all the way back to
you know the the 15 days to slow the
spread becoming 30 days and so on and so
forth we do hear about policy here we do
hear about from doctors and the
questions are interesting so I think I
am committing to muting Mike Pence the
Mike Pence portion is really worthless
like it's acutely worthless and he's
never announcing the new policy it's
always Trump so I think we've heard
enough times pence say the White House
coronavirus press briefing met this
morning we continue to be impressed by
the resilience and cooperation of the
American public and the 30 days to slow
the spread by follower thank you for
your leadership mr. president when it
comes to PPE and masks we have scheduled
57 air bridge flights the pilots are
considering whether they will be wearing
sneakers or shoes during those flights
and at a certain point we are going to
be placing another order for 75 million
masks we never know if the masks are
delivered the numbers are essentially
meaningless it's of such little value
that today at least I have other stuff
planned so we will mute pence and I have
other things that that we can talk about
I'll just read super chats because we're
not going to do any more of the pen
stuff with the Trump part I'll just try
my best to fact-check in real-time and
then of course when we hear from doctors
we want to hear from doctors although
dr. Burks is increasingly also
a vector of disinformation and we've got
doctor foul fee though although he is
increasingly rarely speaking at these
and then the questions from the
reporters we do want to want to listen
to and actually have some interesting
examples of that to play for you from
yesterday
very interesting stuffed Ronald Donald
Trump highly triggered by being
questioned by a woman doing the entire
who you with and relax relax and could
you lower your voice please
which if you if you're familiar with
Trump's personality is not particularly
surprising so welcome today scheduled
for 5:30 p.m. Eastern Time the bottom of
the hour we've got about a half hour
during which we can discuss things if
you don't want to discuss things skip
ahead a half hour if you're watching the
replay of this that we've uploaded to
our YouTube channel I see people already
getting banned and timed out which is
just delightful I've not even done
anything yet but people are already
furious with me
so the moderators are the moderators
know what they're doing here we do also
have a membership goal today I'll talk
about that a little bit later
first some updates first and foremost we
are now on the precipice of 2.5 million
global official cases at this point you
know we have ranges that the real number
is anywhere from two to eighty times
that do I think it's eighty
I don't think so do I think it's two no
I think the official number has to be
well more than two hundred and seventy
thousand deaths here in the United
States we are now past three quarters of
a million known cases the real number is
much higher 42,000 deaths
let's take a look at just the trend
lines and then we'll go up and look at
some other things we still seem to be in
a sort of plateau that's beginning to be
a decline but of course we're starting
to see some of those states that people
are going wild protesting and doing
other things we are starting to see
cases spike on a percentage basis there
the numbers are still low if you have
3,000 cases you might have 300 more in
one day that's bad but on a number basis
it's not that bad
but on a percentage basis if every day
you're adding 10 to 12 percent that's
gonna get ugly very very soon when it
comes to active cases it's starting just
to to
smooth out a little bit and then looking
at deaths we are again hoping that we
are starting to see a peak you know we
thought we might have hit a peak on
April 7th because we had basically a
leveling off all the way until April 13
on the 14th this is because a bunch of
deaths were reclassified as Cova deaths
but in any case a new peak on April 15th
and then we were back down then up again
and then now down a couple days we are
likely in a plateau if we continue
social distancing a lot of the let'em
die Republicans are furious about social
distancing tomorrow I'll have a
commentary on the show about that lastly
I am not that interested in continuing
to show the the ih Emmy model because
number one at this point we're in it the
model tells us very little we have the
day-to-day like if we're in a peak we'll
know because soon we'll be at 1,400
deaths a day and then 1200 the model has
often been outside of his estimates I
don't know if there's much value for me
showing you the model what I do want to
track daily with you though our testing
totals because what is ultimately going
to determine when the country can even
consider reopening and when I say the
country it'll be state by state
decisions we must be doing more testing
yesterday we had a record amount of
testing a hundred and sixty seven
thousand tests today as a for PA these
are updated at 4:00 p.m. so their
24-hour cycles today only a hundred and
thirty seven thousand if we want a real
shot at reopening I'm gonna give you the
tiered okay at a bare minimum what bit
we can't even have a conversation about
reopening until we're at five hundred
thousand tests a day that number may be
way too low another series of roadmaps
say we need to be testing one to five
million per day and then a couple of
roadmaps say you need to be able to test
the whole country every two weeks which
is about 22 million tests a day what I
can tell you for sure is a hundred and
thirty seven thousand tests a day is not
going to cut it it's it's there's not
even a conversation to be had at a
hundred and thirty seven thousand tests
today if we
can keep increasing then we can start to
get there but as you can see you know we
got to 162 on April 9th and then it went
down and then we got to 167 yesterday
and then it went down
we need sustained additional testing
part of this will be new labs coming on
new types of tests and also eventually
as dr. Burke said moving from an RNA
test to an antigen test I am NOT an
expert on that but that that is a way to
scale up testing dr. Burke saying with
an RNA test you can never test you know
millions of people a day is unlikely
when you're dealing with with an RNA
test so we are standing by here for the
White House coronavirus press briefing
on Monday April 20th I want to welcome
you if you're watching on Twitter
Facebook twitch or YouTube if you are
watching on YouTube please do me the
favor of hitting that like button and
hit the subscribe button as well let's
look at a few Super chats coming in
waffles jirafa says do you miss saying
boo de jedge or Buddha itch I really
don't it's actually stunning to me how
quickly I forgot about saying boo de
jedge or about Pete altogether Grace Lee
says who is the cute dog on your
Instagram is he yours that's my dad's
dog
Captain Nemo or just Nemo Nemo Pakman as
I know him Christie J says David what do
you know about the delay of stimulus
checks and the lack of info on the IRS
website updates not happening
frustrating as there seemed to be no
answers I know nothing other than what's
been publicly said and it seems that
there are delays happening for sure
Rocco Delaware says David what's your
opinion on the people who are protesting
the stay at home orders as well as the
president's liberate states tweets I
think it's all toxic and disgusting I
have a clip coming out about it later
and I have some stuff to show you as
well so we'll get to that rat cracker
says ben shapiro called you out in a
video called ben shapiro and steven
crowder discussed the plan to reopen
america at the time stamp of 654 watch
it let's see if I can find that that's
interesting to me uh reopen America
two days ago at the 654 if the 654
timestamp is something totally unrelated
to me and I'm just getting trolled here
that would be funny it wouldn't be the
first time but let's let's take a look
at it together 654 let's start it a
little early here we go on because as
testing is more accurate it'll you know
it'll be a smaller portion of the
overall infection race and that makes a
difference because if we all go out and
infect each other and then it makes that
the kind of overall number of deaths
that we expect a lot lower so as far as
yes as far as overall numbers that we
expect what I am saying is I think the
most at the most accurate metric as far
as what we should be using for people to
sort of assess their risk because a lot
of this was oh my gosh we're seeing at
one point I said a 10% mortality rate
then a five percent then a three percent
and now like well we don't know the
mortality rate 654 but they predicted
2.5 million deaths then a minute and
then a minimum with social distancing
which was supposed to have kicked in a
hundred thousand two hundred forty
thousand and then 60,000 the overall and
I think especially when comparing it
across countries the most active do we
have is the per capita death rate here's
why because you eliminate more variables
in the sense that alright you go to per
capita right so that matters I guess I
mean I don't if he doesn't really
mention me I don't know about even
watching this but I guess that that you
know if you tricked me into showing ben
shapiro and steven crowder I think most
of my audience are already sort of has a
good sense for them so I I guess I don't
know I guess it was just a joke from rat
cracker I don't know if I if we got the
timecode wrong just let me know
Daniel Krieger says official oil prices
super chat yes big oil price discussion
coming up tomorrow
Zachary Foster says my best friend is in
med school at Boston you says there was
a study of 400 homeless in Boston all
those tested positive or asymptomatic
what are your thoughts haven't seen the
study but the asymptomatic stuff seems
to be very very very serious rat cracker
says when are you going on Joe Rogan's
podcast mmm announcement soon I guess
announcement soon Samantha and by the
way I've been on you can see my
appearance that I did already
Samantha Sabatino says pence will not be
missed you could even mute Trump's
planned remarks for all I care I just
care about the now
theists of the questions thank you for
streaming my pleasure my pleasure okay
let me do okay let me do a couple things
real quick first just a couple of new
member thank-yous Paul Delaney is new
member number one today at join
pakman.com thanks Paul Maureen Zoar
Mayer is new member number two Missy
Gutierrez Kauffman is new member number
three Dianne P chat kheh is new member
number four at join pakman.com and Chuck
kneeler or Chuck nyle ur Neil Tyler is
new member number five at join
pakman.com I'll say a little bit more
about that later okay let's get to a
couple of other things judge Jeanine
over the weekend gave maybe her most
unhinged performance yet on her fox news
program we understand people are dying
but what about the rest of the sheltered
in their homes who've been patiently
watching this unfold have seen the data
and the facts changed from day to day
first there were 2.2 million who were
supposed to die in the United States and
then it was a million then it was
500,000 then 250,000 and supposedly
mitigation was already taken into
account yes that's not true
the 2.2 million is if no one did
anything which no you know no president
could get away with just simply saying
we're not doing anything so that's a lie
it's numbers but the models folks are
just plain wrong and today a potentially
lower death rate and we understand there
are still many sick and dying and
density and hot spots are to be treated
differently but what about the rest of
us we want to go back to work well the
rest she's working first of all and the
rest of us hopefully get to live judge
Jeanine so we'll have full coverage of
that unhinged rant tomorrow here oh this
is just more this is more stuff oh she
brought on a pro - I'm not even gonna
play this for you now she brought on a
protester to praise the protester and
talked about how proud she is of the
protester it's really really crazy so
there's that Trump supporting the
protesters tweeting as you can see here
let me zoom the same
liberate Minnesota liberate Michigan
liberate Virginia and save your great
second-amendment it is under siege if
you want to cause violence then you tell
Republicans that someone's trying to
take their guns that's a great way to
get people going absolutely crazy then
here is Donald Trump triggered by a
female reporter asking real questions
Trump does the misogynistic trifecta
he says who you who you with who do you
work for that's number one number two is
telling her to relax and calm down and
then number three is telling her to
lower her voice notice that he never
answers the question by the way you that
you should have warned them the virus
was spreading like wildfire
through the month of February instead of
quoting rallies with thousands of people
why did you wait so long and why did you
not have social distancing until March
16th I'm with CBS News so there's number
one the hole who you would think Mitch
McConnell did that recently to a female
reporter as well if you look at what I
did in terms of cutting off or banning
China from coming in that's so
patronizing nice and easy nice and easy
just relax
and then it continues we cut it off
people were amazed these gentlemen
everybody was amazed that I did it we
had 21 people in a room everybody was
against it but me doctor foul she said
had I not done that perhaps tens of
thousands and maybe much more than that
people would have died I was very early
very very early and we just saw you saw
Brett Baier making a statement they had
a debate well into February and not even
mentioned it wasn't even mentioned the
Democrats we were very early on
and you know what I just is and you know
what I just when you issue the ban the
virus was always here okay and you know
how many people when I issued the ban
how many cases of virus were in the
United States when I wish you'd the
banjee know the number no no how many
cases remember I said one person how
many cases were here when I issued the
ban
cuz you never know know if you have to
be a researcher how many the 23rd of
March you said you knew this was going
to be a pen can I tell you what I did
know it I did not all I have to do is
love you look for anybody knew it just
are you ready how many cases were in the
United States what I did my band how
many people had died in the United
States now keep your voice down
so that anyway anyway it's it's the
trifecta and we know Trump doesn't
really know how to relate to women this
is why he's had to pay a lot of women a
hundred thousand dollars after having
sex with them like we know this is not a
guy who relates to women in the way that
that you know many many of us do so so
there's that will have a clip about that
later today um here is doctor foul Chee
schooling Laura Ingraham about how you
know viruses work it's crazy that he
still has to even answer questions like
this we don't have a vaccine for SARS I
mean they got close and mice we don't
have a vaccine for HIV and life did go
on right so the idea that we're
definitely going to have a vaccine we
did we didn't really approach much else
in the same way as we're pegging going
back to normal with a vaccine did we
well no but Laura this is different
hiv/aids is entirely different we don't
have a vaccine for hiv/aids but we have
spectacularly effective treatment now
the other thing about HIV is you can't
go to work and sneeze and give ten
people HIV seems worth mentioning right
that that is why are we even talking
about HIV because the the spread of it
is completely different people who
invariably would have died years ago
right now a leading essentially normal
lives SARS is a different story
saws disappeared we developed a vaccine
we're in the pre we're in the process of
going through the various phases we
showed it with
safe we showed it induced a good
response and then SARS disappeared and
we didn't need to develop a vaccine for
saw so I think it's it's a little bit
misleading maybe a compare what we're
going through now with HIV or SARS
they're really different but we don't
know this could disappear
I mean SARS did pretty much disappear
this could as well crap yeah you know it
you know anything could Laura Oh
transmissibility of this is is really
unprecedented in anything that I've seen
it's an extraordinarily efficient virus
in transmitting from one person to
another yeah I took like three months
for China to get a 5,000 cases of SARS
it didn't take three months this time
around so anyway I don't actually think
Laura Ingraham is that dumb she has you
know she hasn't
she's a degree from Dartmouth she has a
juris doctor she's a lawyer
she went to law school she's not
actually this dumb I think it seems to
me that she just has sort of put you
know you know is playing along with what
Fox News has determined is going to be
their perspective or their positioning
on this at this point in time we're
standing by for today's White House
coronavirus press briefing we've decided
we are going to be muting Mike Pence
that his participation is superfluous
and and meaningless in fact and actually
acted aggressively negative in many ways
so we'll be muting Mike Pence when he
comes up I am able to be oh so we I
actually am hosting a debate tonight via
Skype which is not going to be live but
we need our equipment to record the
debate I'll tell you more about that
later so I'll stay as long as I can but
when I get the thumbs up that the guests
are ready for the debate I'll have to
end my stream I can't stream and do a
debate at the same time but I should be
here for the for the bulk of it today
let me say some thank yous to fantastic
people on Twitch I want to say thanks to
Nikki 206 who has subscribed with Prime
and nug Wrangler has subscribed with
prime for eight months okay
remember if you were watching on YouTube
I so much appreciate every
but hitting the like button and the
subscribe button that really helps us
out some super chats that are coming in
let's see here Zack Bushman whoa hold on
a second
Zack Bushman says friendly reminder to
launch a Trident to ICBM nuclear strike
on the like button and catch the
subscribe button in the blast radius yes
I couldn't say it better myself
lisa kline war says the weekly chip in
to thank you for helping us to bear this
insanity thanks Lisa young dumb and
Baroque says hey David just wondering
where do you land on the great simp
debate between Ray asuka and masato
choose wisely now you know I don't know
anything about Garfield comics so
unfortunately I wouldn't be able to
answer that JR says when I hear my
computer sound the alert that you will
be starting your stream soon it's like a
doorbell ringing announcing the visit of
a welcomed and trusted friend come on in
that's such a nice thing to say Jay I
love that I appreciate that
pandaman says hey David can you send me
some of your pubic hair so that I can
preserve the DNA of the second-hottest
news commentator you know I don't know
why you need to go for second place just
go go for your dreams go to whoever is
your number one porthole says which
party is a death cult and why yeah you
come on you guys know the answer to that
Anthony Starke says why is nobody
talking about the second wave or the
pandemic of the pandemic is it canceled
I've been talking about the second wave
that's all I can tell you
unknown prodigy says when are you having
another chess tournament soon maybe
later this week or possibly next week
would be my my best assessment as of
right now Oz says Kentucky saw a
dramatic spike in kovat cases after
protests you think we'll be seeing more
in the following weeks yes and I'm going
to talk about the Kentucky situation
tomorrow for sure
rat cracker says will you debate Kyle
kolinsky over voting Biden I don't know
it's C everybody knows my perspective I
think that such a debate could only
serve to further divide the left and I
don't want to do that I want to
remove Trump alms has subscribed on
YouTube Daniel Rivera says what are your
thoughts of people looking at the 22
million lost jobs and blaming the
lockdowns and wanting to reopen the
economy as a result of that well I've
talked about that so much today and I
have multiple clips coming out about
that today that I'm going to forego
going into that right now
rat cracker says please do a response to
Stephen Crowder's but I don't care I
don't care about steven crowder you
tricked me already getting me to put on
one of his videos but i don't care about
steven crowder John Howell says support
independent journalism thank you John
Matt Jette met Chet has subscribed
Michael Hank Lee says David what
keyboard did you end up going with for
now I just put new batteries back in my
standard Adele wireless keyboard it's a
completely beta keyboard in fact I'm
risking my reputation as a Chad by even
admitting that I have this keyboard in
fact here okay it's gone I got rid of it
because I've been told you never want to
admit that you have this keyboard but I
am looking at see here's the thing I
don't know that I should have a
mechanical keyboard for a live stream
because aren't they incredibly loud that
seems like it would be a real problem I
don't I don't I don't want to be you
know dealing with that okay let's see
here other super chats coming in Julie
Chow dari
says just sprinkle pixie dust and make
it disappear Ben Rowan says your lover
Kyle kolinsky won't vote for Biden how
do you feel about this come on guys come
on Andrew Stewart says your best nasty
but fair question try I know I don't
know if I was really in a position to
ask from questions I would give it more
thought than just you know a spur of the
moment answer to a super chat Pedro
Guzman the third says why while I am on
the right wing in terms of political
position I enjoy enjoy your opinion
because it's the closest to reality the
left can produce as possible the
left didn't produce me my friend my
parents did oh boy more these spam calls
coming in on my phone
Nunez says beta soy boy keyboard lmao
yes
I apologized I apologize that my
keyboard is so very beta what can I do
we are anticipating that we are just a
few minutes from the start of today's
White House coronavirus press briefing I
want to invite you the best way the by
far the best way to support these
streams and everything we do is to grab
a membership at join pakman.com it
doesn't take a lot it doesn't take a
high level of technical skill it doesn't
take a long time it's just a handful of
clicks the website is joined pakman.com
we have suffered a setback I would say
in the world of independent media whoa
this guy's right in my face that's
distracting in the world of independent
media as a result of the virus we lost
389 members in March we were down about
120 in April because we're all in this
together and those folks that can't
afford membership anymore it's fine
we're here for you we're doing the
streams we're doing the content but if
you are in the boat of someone who can
afford a couple months month bucks a
month and you reasonably like me if you
don't like me you just you know troll on
through and go right on if you
reasonably like me and you value what
we're doing and you can afford a couple
bucks a month consider getting a
membership at join pakman.com the coupon
code over my head 20 20 now will save
you 66% that discount is illegal in some
of the southern states it's too big of a
discount for independent media but we're
based in Massachusetts and thus it is
allowed and I will thank every single
person who grabs a membership I want to
say along those lines thanks to Elsie
Messman who is new member number 6
Andrew Lewis who's new member number 7
Francisco Barbosa in Argentina we'd call
you back Oh Francisco often nicknamed as
Paco number 8 today and I believe that
catches me
yes I believe I'm caught up so that is
my appeal to you today ignore it at your
pleasure as I always say but I do
appreciate everybody who's been who's
been supporting let's see here other
super chats coming in where did I leave
off okay Daniel Rivera says you can get
those keyboards with silent hinges I
could get a mechanical keyboard that is
a quiet mechanical keyboard all right
very good I'm learning as we go here
Robin Anderson sends a super chat Lee
Douglas says how is your girlfriend
doing much love to you both she's doing
fine thank you
a Sarah S sends a super chat panda man
says my number one hottest is Pat oh my
goodness we have a Pat fan in the in the
super chat Ben cuentas has subscribed as
has Jeannie hunt Stephen Jackson says
these briefings don't seem to ever start
when scheduled has that been the case in
previous administrations I don't
actually know under previous
administrations how typically they
started late thanks to Barry Steinberg
for subscribing also chef Sevan says
we're smoking a fatty together after
this right Dave I I certainly don't
smoke anything very bad for your lungs
puts you at additional risk for a
serious case of kovat 19a certainly no
smoking for me a couple of opal asking
what do I have going on it's not much
not much really I did bike on on
Saturday I wore a mask and a face shield
and a beekeepers outfit so I was
relatively well protected
I ordered a an espresso scale so that's
coming in tomorrow and I will be now I'm
so you know I'm so going stir-crazy
that I'm going to be weighing espresso
down to a tenth of a gram can you
imagine can you imagine more ridiculous
behavior than weighing out my espresso
no but in all seriousness I've got a
great espresso machine and I've never
learned to really use it manually I used
pre pre measured shot volumes and I am
now going
I'm moving on and we will be weighing
everything down to a tenth of a gram my
friends oh and also I got a cubic yard
of soil delivered today and I will be
planting all sorts of vegetables in the
next couple of days I've got radish
seeds I've got carrot seeds snow peas
what else I guess that's it I'm growing
some stuff indoors as well and I'll
transfer it outside around Mother's Day
that's all I've got going on I wish I
had more okay
Charlie says David what's the current
cost to like this stream it's free the
likes are free so much like the bands
are free we just hand out bands it costs
us nothing as people require bands you
can also like the stream for free I
don't know why I do a whack-a-mole
motion for liking the stream but like
the stream and make sure to hit that
subscribe button let me say a huge thank
you to waken bacons who has just
subscribed with twitch prime prime over
at twitch.tv slash David Pakman very
exciting stuff what else
[Music]
Browdy Andrew Mulligan says in Texas
your discount equals jail
que lastima Pedrito yeah a piddly though
I don't know that we need an accent over
the Oh Brody but yeah in fact we can't
even offer six to 66% discount in Texas
Greg Abbott would personally arrest me
and put me in a cage if I were to do
that
Joseph Ernst says are the Republicans
setting
DeWine up for a presidential run at some
point maybe not at not a totally crazy
candidate to imagine Danny Thompson says
I sent a super chat to you the day you
mentioned picking up painting again
about thinking of you and Bob Ross hair
painting happy little trees you made my
weekend when I saw it come to life on
your Facebook feed yeah on our Instagram
and Facebook feeds we put up a picture
of me photoshopped on to Bob Ross if
Danny if you are the source of that
photo
shop then thank you for creating that AC
says I hope all is well I gave up coffee
so here's the $5 I would have spent
thank you I don't know if that's for
real
Micah Gelfand says where can I send you
some edibles no need to damage your
pretty lungs David do not send any drugs
through the mail we have reason to
believe that our post-office box is
being very closely monitored by
authorities that seek to take down the
David Pakman show and we don't want any
drugs showing up at our p o-- box I'm
mostly kidding about that okay let me
say thank you to a few other people here
okay Trevor Patterson is new member
number nine at join pakman.com Victoria
Zhang is new member number 10 at join
pakman.com Michael Mills or Mills is new
member number 11
hyung Leung yang is new member number 12
Linda Monaco is lucky 13 Scott Gor you
are new member number 14 today
whoa something just went haywire on my
end I want to say thanks to Sherry right
who is new member number 15 Brian
Dominguez is new member number 16 also
thank you to Jurgen Rydell Jurgen Rydell
is number 17
Marcus Rhys Harris is new member number
18 Melanie Branagh
is number 19 and Fiona is it fair Clow
or Faircloth Faircloth is new member
number 20 today lastly Andrew garibay is
new member number 21 very much
appreciate the support very very much
appreciate it you're just joining us we
should just be minutes from the start a
couple of announcements today number one
I have to go and moderate a debate in a
little over an hour so I'll stay as long
as I can at a certain point tragically
we will probably have to prematurely
pinch off the stream because I have to
go moderate a debate using all the same
equipment so I can't be streaming and
moderating a debate at the same time but
hopefully we'll get to most of today we
will also be muting Mike Pence I've
determined that his cut his
contributions are not only of no value
they are acutely frustrating and they
make me nauseous hearing him talk about
you know the air bridge we've scheduled
flights and we're get we've got millions
of masks it's just of no value
whatsoever so we will be muting we're
gonna drop the mute on Mike Pence a
little bit later let me say thank you to
glorious Esteban for subscribing with
twitch Prime and New York jailhouse who
has also subscribed with twitch prime
super chats continue to roll in rat
cracker says as a libertarian socialist
I've been doing a lot of research on
harm reduction versus acceleration ISM
for capitalism there are very few good
arguments against harm reduction where
are you in this debate I am on the harm
reduction side squarely very very
squarely very strongly even Joseph van
Scoy says would a Warren VP nominee
nomination get apprehensive Bernie Bros
on board it would get a fraction of them
on board but not all of them Daniel
Rivera says the people want more Pakman
Coffee videos yes I will be doing more
espresso videos as soon as my espresso
scale comes in Matt Chavez says
protesters have unprotected kids with
them is that child abuse it's certainly
neglectful certainly neglectful for sure
magic X B says what are your thoughts on
Georgia removing restrictions on 4:24
seems absurd that these southern states
placed the economy over health I didn't
see that Florida was that a Georgia was
doing that I saw that Texas and South
Carolina were but if Georgia is then we
will certainly research that but it
seems very premature Anna Burgos says
have you bought any stocks or had your
eye on any you know I have not bought
any stocks for I I made most of the buys
I'm going to tell you about today and
remember we're killing time here let me
turn up the audio
so that we don't miss when this starts
we're just chatting until this starts
here are the stocks that I have bought
since the start of this but everything's
been at least at least a month ago I
bought zoom ZM this has gone where has
it gone I bought everything I want to
say it was right around man when when
did I buy these does anybody remember
because I said when I bought it I think
it was right around here uh I don't know
I'm up somewhat yeah I think I was in
around 136 something like that so I
bought zoom because it seems a lot of
people are gonna be using zoom I bought
Roku I've owned next Netflix for years
and years so it didn't seem like I
didn't I didn't buy more Netflix but I
think it was right around Mart yeah
right around here I bought Roku right
around here so that one's doing well
what else did I buy I did buy some bear
on the idea that maybe chloroquine would
be effective so I bought right around
March 20th it is up about 20% since then
but it doesn't seem like
hydroxychloroquine is gonna be the thing
certainly I bought it before Trump
started talking about it let me put it
that way
I did buy Live Nation my idea with Live
Nation was they're gonna get crushed in
the short term as they have I think
right around March mid March I bought
but at some point live events are going
to be a thing so that was the idea
shockingly it's actually up if I was in
at 29 it's at 36 now and there was one
other stock I bought although I don't
remember now what it was those are the
moves and again as I've said before I
don't I I think that you know I don't
think I'm good at picking stocks I think
very few people are good at picking
stocks I mostly have mutual funds very
broad mutual funds total stock market
index total global stock market index
but you know that's it and then as many
of you know famously I have had Tesla
stock for a very very long time and I've
had Amazon and Netflix stock for a very
very long time
Sirius XM radio I think is the only
other stock I have okay let's see let me
thank a few other people now we're
getting into some complicated names here
let me see if I can pronounce these oh
dear Christopher Kia Manawa Hammond Iowa
no boy is new member number 22 today at
join pakman.com whoa
something something went wrong there
number 22 Lisa Koziol is new member
number 23 at join pakman.com and Lucinda
Hanson is number 24 we are just shy of
our goal of 25 as dr. Burks has entered
the room I am increasingly lukewarm on
dr. Burks after some of the whoppers
she's mentioned the fact that the TV's
are on is not a good sign it suggests
there will be propaganda a retro path
Act says is Biden to progressivism as
Bieber is to music I don't know enough
about Bieber to say VIN vintage item
though vintage items store I see Trump
red states to reopen suppress dem voting
I don't know I'm not sure exactly that
I'm parsing that correctly I apologize
where did that go Adrianne benningfield
says David if you reach a certain
membership goal an idea could be you
reading Animal Farm
if legal in videos could be great you
know I'm not sure if the audience wants
to see me read Animal Farm I don't know
that that would do well I think that
that may even get me but to have to see
cancellations go up that's very scary I
don't know that's a good idea
Oh Meg aya oh no sorry Bruce Robinson
says why is it that liquor stores are
essential but recreational marijuana is
non-essential and not available I
thought here in Massachusetts
Oh recreational yeah that's a good
question I don't know the answer to that
it seems a little incongruous Oh Meg
ayah says hey David when you're trying
to convince some to vote Biden remind
them of age V bar he might just start
rounding up secular humanists who talk
too much
okay here is your trauma let's switch
over to okay we'll switch over in a
little bit hold on following the release
of our reopening guidelines governor's
across the country are looking forward
to phase one and announcing plans for an
economic resurgence we're gonna have a
research okay I'm gonna switch to c-span
because as you know if they have better
audio it's on a ten second delay better
audio though and they show you reporters
asking questions thank you thank you
following the release of our reopening
guidelines governor's across the country
are looking forward to phase one and
announcing plans for an economic
resurgence we're going to have a
resurgence - at a time when millions of
American workers and families are
struggling with the financial
consequences of the virus it's critical
to continue the medical war while
reopening the economy in a safe and
responsible fashion during this time
Americans must maintain strict vigilance
and continue to practice careful hygiene
social distancing and the other
protective measures that we have
outlined and that everybody's become
very familiar with we continue to be
encouraged that many of the area's
hardest hit by the virus appear to have
turned the corner for example recent
deaths are down very very substantially
you can compare that with their peak not
so long ago and you have numbers
fact-check we've got a plateau in some
places southern states climbing rapidly
it's down by over 50% congratulations
and in New Orleans where they've done a
terrific job that down sixty-five
percent thirty states have just one case
or less per 1000 people far fewer cases
per capita as an example than Germany
the United Kingdom France Italy Ireland
Switzerland Singapore Belgium Spain
Norway the Netherlands Austria Sweden my
administration continues to press
Congress to replenish the enormous ly
successful paycheck protection program
which has impacted 30 million American
jobs
we hope to have in tons of small
businesses unable to get any money and
likely will fail permanently sadly a lot
of progress has been made on that
tremendous progress it's a great plan
it's a great plans helped a lot of
people so we hope to have a vote maybe
tomorrow in the Senate and based on the
record low price of oil that you've been
seeing at a level that's very
interesting to a lot of people we're
filling up our national petroleum
reserves strategic you know the
strategic reserves this is a real sham
so for weeks Trump has been saying the
price is too low we've got to raise it
working with Russia and Saudi Arabia to
raise it now that clearly it's beyond
his control he's going to act like it's
a good thing despite previously acting
like it's a bad thing we're talking
about a total con man here we're also
pushing for the deal to include an
additional 75 billion our deal deal
we're talking about seventy five billion
dollars for hospitals and other
healthcare providers many providers and
their employees have taken a huge
financial hit in recent weeks and visits
elective procedures surgeries etc etc
were cancelled we think that they can
all get back online
they'll get it done hospitals have
really been fantastic the hospitals many
places not doing that they've stepped up
to the plate they're really done a great
job we appreciate it so much four areas
less affected by the virus we've issued
new recommendations about how to safely
resume elective treatments HHS has also
distributed the first 30 billion dollars
in direct payments to a million health
care providers across the country we've
also invested one point four billion
dollars in community health centers to
ensure our most vulnerable communities
including many African American and
Hispanic American communities have
access to the services and testing that
they need earlier today vice president
pence spoke with governors from all 50
states about our unified effort to
defeat the virus he had a great call
that was a great call very positive and
I'd say every way prior to the call we
provided each governor with a list
the names addresses and phone numbers of
the labs where they can find additional
testing capacity within their states
many many labs we're providing you with
the list we'll show it to you now if you
need it we'll give you the details but
hundreds and hundreds of labs are ready
willing and able and some of the
governor's like as an example the
governor from Maryland didn't really
understand the list he didn't understand
too much about what was going on so this
is the new shifting of blame on lack of
testing from the federal government to
governor's just as a heads-up its
capacity and we hope to be able to help
him out we'll work with them and work
with all of the governor's similar to
the situation with ventilators States
need to assess their complete inventory
of available capacity some states have
far more capacity than they actually
understand and it is a complex subject
but some of the governor's didn't
understand it the governor is an example
pritzker from Illinois did not
understand his capacity he didn't get it
yep not simply ask the federal
government to provide imagine if during
a pandemic Obama listed governor's who
just didn't understand do you have it
but we are there to stand with the
governors and to help the governors and
that's what we're doing and they have a
tremendous capacity that we've already
built up and you'll be seeing that we're
gonna be introducing a couple of the
folks in a little while to talk about it
I want to draw your attention to
Governor Cuomo's remarks during his
press conference today he said the
president is right the state's testing
is up to the states to do which will
implement the tests and logistically
coordinate the tests we have about 300
labs in New York and they do their great
labs actually it's my job to coordinate
those 300 labs I think the president's
right when he says that the states
should lead and the governor's really
they're really getting they're getting
it together in New York a lot of good
things are happening in New York and I
think the governor is going to come in
to see us tomorrow he's coming to the
Oval Office tomorrow afternoon it's not
a good idea for Cuomo to do bring in
with some of his people so we look
forward to that
the some of the articles it just
recently came about if you remember and
I put out a statement today for a month
it was well ventilator ventilator
ventilated so people could talk about
was ventilators and we did a great job
with that we built a lot of ventilators
to put it mildly we have so many now
that at some point soon we're gonna be
helping Mexico and Italy and other
countries he doesn't actually seem like
we have that many it seems many are in
production they were in a position they
were not in a position to build them
themselves but we have thousands being
built every state has had they have the
ventilators if they don't we have almost
10,000 in our federal reserve our suck
file as they call it and we did a great
job with the ventilators unfortunately
the press doesn't cover it
other than the fair press but so then
you say gee I they need ventilators we
don't need ventilators not that that's
under pressure we did that nobody that
needed a ventilator this country didn't
get one I believe that and a story that
just came out how the media completely
blew the Trump ventilator story I'm sure
you would love to see that that's by
rich Lowry journalist in person that how
the media community blew that comment
latest er which unfortunately it did and
here's another one that just came out
Kyle Smith the ventilator shortage that
wasn't the ventilator shortage that
wasn't because we got it fixed and we're
also going to help the states by the way
stockpile ventilator so if a thing like
this should happen again they've got him
imagine Obama the stories on testing are
all over the place that we're actually
in good shape I'm gonna have the vice
president and others speak to you about
that but weren't very good shooting that
oh and testing and we're getting better
all the time you're gonna see some
interesting things I thought before I
went any further though I'd like to have
general seminyak who's done an
incredible job
tell you where we are you know we're
still building beds and hospitals for
people that need them
I guess the hospital business general is
getting pretty much closed out now but
we're we're creating a lot of space for
people just in case and in some cases
they probably will be using them but I
thought the general isn't so impressive
and does a great job I thought on behalf
of the services and on behalf of the
federal government had say a few words
about what we're doing right now
thank you very much Sheriff well thank
you mr. president I just want you to
know that on behalf of all of us in the
Department of Defense our thoughts and
prayers go out to all of those patients
and all those victims have been affected
by this terrible virus and the president
a vice president talked all the time
about the heroes but we have been out
there I've seen the doctors I've seen
the nurses and all those that have
worked very very hard and we're just
we're just so proud to be part of this
noble calling I for my team I really
made it very very simple I said there's
three legs of this stool and they all
have s's there are sites where in other
words hospitals we've got to worry about
supplies and we've got to worry about
staff and so right when Governor Cuomo
called the president about almost 30
days ago he said I need some help
worrying about what could be tens of
thousands of hotel-room I mean of
hospital room shortages so the President
and Secretary of Defense asked us to fly
to Albany with the team and on the way
up we understood how complex of a
challenge this was and we knew there's
no way you can solve in Flex catastrophe
with a complicated solution we needed a
very very simple solution to be able to
then work with HHS to be able to work
with FEMA to be able to work with the
vice president's task force is loud and
then to be able to power this down all
the way down to the local level some of
the governor's asked us to try to build
a hospital in a parking lot or a field
in two or three weeks you can't
physically do that so what we said was
let's go to where there's an existing
facility and I'm going to kind of make
this in two big pots those that are
either hotel rooms or college
dormitories smaller rooms or those that
are in real large areas like field
houses or convention centers and we
design those standard facilities that
could be either non kovat or coded and
then we got that approved
the federal government to be able to
then power that back down so we went to
Governor Cuomo and he said right up
front I love the concept I need you in
the Javits Center I'm ready to start
having your work tomorrow afternoon so
when we flew back that afternoon the
next day we basically built the standard
design and then continued to be able to
power it down all the way down through
the rest of the team so I just want to
show you a couple slides here and we'll
will kind of let you know where we're at
right now mr. president we had to do a
bunch of assessments so somewhere in the
order of over 1100 different locations
we went to and we work for FEMA we work
for the president and we work for
governors and mayors and we said what do
you think your demand is gonna be and
based on a lot of the modeling that's
been in this room here notice how
they're always talking about like we're
this is not actually the ish this is
delightful and we're thrilled with beds
of course we need beds no doubt but the
issue right now mostly is testing the
issue is protesters that are going to be
super spreaders of the disease so it
always feels like they're talking about
the thing that they should have been
talking about ten days prior but
complete and in the next week and a half
we're gonna complete about 15 more
facilities we've got some pending some
mayors and governors are still wondering
do they have enough bed space and what's
important here is we need a very agile
plan you can't do something three weeks
ago and think that this is going to
continue to stay because this virus gets
a vote in this entire team the federal
government's try to be as agile as they
can support in those states and those
governors the beauty of the paint plan
though was it doesn't have to be built
by the United States Army Corps of
Engineers so we designed about an extra
52 facilities we gave those to the
governor's and I've got to be very very
laudatory to the governor's they then
imposed and put a lot of those on there
on the ground and did those themselves
so let's go go I'm just going to show
you some real simple pictures here go to
the next slide if you don't mind so this
is an example of the Javits Center and
you've heard the president talk about it
quite a few times this one about 2100
bed spaces what this is what we call
filler like we've the pictures of the
Javits Center on April 20th are not
newsworthy it's a beautiful facility I
love that they have the beds it's great
we saw this a month ago right it's very
weird maybe not a month okay do not
don't take me literally their central
oxygen so everybody has oxygen right
behind their bed to be able to take care
of those patients and again built this
one about a thousand pound patients
treated let's go to the next one I was
up in Detroit with governor whit Muir
and she walked us through and told us
her intent here's what she needed to do
this in the TCF center you'll see all
the cubicles that are laid out this is
right in the middle of a convention
floor where there might be like a boat
show or a car show and then went in and
a builds nine hundred and seventy
different capabilities there and again a
lot of great work by my guys in the
Corps of Engineers and the rest of the
mayors and the Seas team all pulling
together let's go to the next one this
is called the mccormick place governor
prettiest saddest down he said here's
kind of our intent or what you want to
do nervous mayor Lightfoot walked us
through and we went into another large
convention center this is actually three
thousand bed spaces a very very large
build and got this one done in a
relatively short time and then here's
another one that kind of helps you
understand the dynamic here go to the
next one please this is in Miami Beach
and I flew in to see governor two
Santa's and my guys had kind of scoped
out about 450 beds and he said Todd how
long is gonna bake take to build us and
we kind of said probably until the 27th
of April and he went to his little
health people he said how long do you
need they said the day we need us is the
21st of April and I told my guys you
don't have till the 27th figure out how
to get it done by the 20th this is where
you don't get to build to be able to
have the perfect solution you've got to
be able to get the mission-essential
done lives are on the line here and
we've got to be able to get everything
done to be able to save those lives and
let's go to the last one here this is
one we're doing right now Colorado this
is in Denver another gigantic convention
center you'll see all the different
cubicles here to be able to just bring
in that oxygen 6-inch copper pipe that
comes in and it's all pipe throughout
the entire convention awesome high six
miles of pipe that's able to go in to be
able to make that happen and in closing
I just want to be able to say that we
are very very focused in the Corps of
Engineers getting this done but this is
all about the team the federal team the
state team the local team the vice
president's Task Force and a lot of the
people sitting
here have informed us of how fast we
need to go and it goes back to again all
the layer the governors and the mayors
of make a bet this happened but I want
to reiterate President Trump has called
me three times in secretary espera has
been on the phone at least one of those
times and said what else do we need to
do to set you up for success is there
any other knobs we can turn to be able
to help you go and you think about that
equation of those 3 s's I think that
with the federal government and the
mayors in the cities here we've
effectively taken that first s out of
the equation and so I can't tell you of
all the things I've done in my career
this is a noble calling to be able to
step up and save American lives
so with that sir I thank you very much
Wow no question so about a week ago we
thought we're about capped at 26 what
we're seeing is as I said the virus gets
a vote we're seeing some of these curves
are stretching out where we might have
thought we only had five or six days we
actually have a couple weeks now other
ones were seeing exactly the opposite so
where we didn't think there was some and
I'm not gonna go into locations here but
we are definitely get requested and
we've got six more requesting just in
the last four or five days there are a
little bit smaller facilities and more
remote areas but our job we still if we
have enough time to go build we want to
get in there do the assessment we work
for the mayor and the city and the
governor here and we can still get them
done if the mayors and those elected
officials make a fast enough decision
very much might give them a little bit
of an update how are we doing with the
wall so sorry I think the most important
thing and you stress this and secretary
Esper stressed this there's really
several different priorities here our
number one priority in in Department of
Defense in the Corps of Engineers is to
protect the team protect the force no
matter what we do we've got to continue
to take care of our civilians and our
servicemembers out there and so every
single thing we're doing whether we're
building for the VA or we're building
for civil works projects or for the
Department of Defense or building on the
southwest border we are going out of our
way I talked to my commanders this
morning we've got over 4,000 contractors
that are on the
around out there and we've had no
positives as was this morning knock on
wood same thing with my 400 employees
we're testing them not necessarily we're
the more stringent test but with
temperatures to be able to make sure
that everybody's safe and everybody goes
out of the way to do things the right
way Construction is going very very
smooth what we're seeing is our
contractors were extremely focused now
that we've we've got a good clear path
both on the CBP program as well as some
of the DoD program we I think very well
postured it's a very very aggressive
build but we're well postured to be able
to meet your expectations for a 450 by
the end of December 2020 164 as of today
64 miles and we'll have it done sometime
pretty early next year very exciting
yes sir understand you promised a wall
across the entire southern border now
when he talks about having it done he's
no longer talking about that it's just
like it never happened it's a rewriting
of history a standard design that you
trust in and it works very well
I've got to cook I've got a pat on the
back Commissioner Morgan he was very
adamant and continued to be able to make
sure that it supports his agents and so
we've got a design now that certainly
does that and then we've got a
phenomenal contractor workforce is that
design you can hop over with parts from
a regular hardware store oh we don't see
any significant problems and I think
it's also important to point out that
there we want to do this the right way
so we try to balance this with
environmental considerations are out
there we're trying to do due diligence
when it comes to anything to do with any
of the citizens are affected we're
trying to make sure that we're
protecting all of the things that we
need to protect and try to find that
balance where we can both meet the
administration's directive while at the
same time making sure we're doing this
so that everybody's gets a vote and
everybody has a fair shake
which are doing regarding the
availability of at the recreation sites
with the Army Corps of Engineers oh I
think you're supposed to have your nose
in the mask so I'm an engineer I take my
guides up some of these experts sitting
on the bench over here and when the
president says turn on America what we
initially did like many many other
governors they you know shut down
beaches shut down cities I had a meeting
with my commanders this morning and as
soon as we think it's safe turn them
back on
I mean parking out there at a rec area
where you're 500 feet away from
everybody in a camper is probably low
threat I will continue to take guidance
from the administration but where we get
green lights to continue to put our rec
areas full up and let everybody go back
out there and do things the safe way I
mean we worked for the administration so
I want to do it safe but I don't want to
be the last guy that turns things on not
at all yes ma'am like black communities
or Latino communities communities of
color are the Army Corps of Engineers
doing anything that would be building
any sort of temporary facilities for
those communities so we basically key
off what the city asked for the city and
the governor there are a couple specific
areas that certain city mayor's have
asked us for again I'm not going to go
into details but we basically if they go
in and say I'm very worried about a hot
spot on this side of town or a specific
community here we will do an S what the
administration's charges is whatever we
can do it to be most responsive we just
don't want a never to have an ambulance
pull up to the back of a hospital and
somebody says we're out of room go to
the next hospital down so that's where
we're trying to make sure that that bed
space is available and so far everything
we built has been ahead of need in other
words we're able to finish the building
two or three days before it's needed
thank you ma'am
you can stay and watch watch these
wonderful people that's this really nice
question so you can go back to the
building sir I got a lot of building to
do I'm gonna lay there - thanks are very
impressive
that's really great thank you very much
he's a terrific gentleman we have a lot
of great people doing that kind of thing
that they really have to get recognition
for the incredible job they're doing
whatever he's I don't think anybody else
could do it nothing like that and that's
on top of thousands and thousands of
hospitals and you know he built just in
New York alone for hospitals and 2,900
beds and got him done so quickly nobody
nobody saw anything like it fortunately
we haven't had to use too many of them
and that's okay that's probably better
news than having to use them all right
because a lot of good things are
happening in New York and elsewhere so
through the public-private partnerships
and deregulation the federal government
has already made immense testing
capabilities available but some states
need to take action to fully utilize it
to date the United States has conducted
millions more tests than any other
country you can add them all up and they
don't catch us and our numbers are
doubling almost on a certainly in a
monthly basis but almost on a weekly
basis we're moving very rapidly for us
how untrue that a number of nobody
thought possible be doubling our number
of daily tests if the governor's bring
their state's fully online through the
capability that they have we have
tremendous capability out there already
existing we haven't and we clearly
that's what the governor today Mike and
all of the people explained it very
strongly to the governor's seat they
really get it now I think so testing has
been level for several weeks it's not
doubling every week it's just untrue
look at the numbers agnostic testing to
treat patients as well as contact
tracing to contain outbreaks and
monitoring to pinpoint potential hot
spots during phase one and there are
some hot spots and we have them
pinpointed and they can
really covered very very nicely when
they know exactly where to go and
they're being told where to go and also
these locations where they're going and
some of them are federal some of the
governor's didn't realize they were
allowed to use federal locations they
are and we have a booklet of the federal
locations we could hold it up I think
you'll show that maybe we'll hold it up
now yeah okay fine but you see the
number of things thanks these are all
locations where they can go oh yeah hold
it up which is really pretty amazing
this is just one page out of many look I
mean it's a lot of locations are
doubling we're stacked and they could
all what is it five thousand so that's
thank you very much that's more than
anybody thought but and it's already
there they have to use it that's all
they have to use it somewhere and aware
some we're very much aware somewhere of
where my administration also continues
to support States with our massive
operation to deliver masks gowns gloves
and other vital supplies admiral paula
shark and his team at fifa literally
that what a job they've done and pete
what a job he's done they're calling on
Easter Sunday to make sure everyone's ok
but they're using detailed data about
supply chains to track the deployment of
1 billion pieces of protective equipment
through private distributors every two
weeks so what we're doing is we're
delivering a number that nobody anywhere
in the world is delivering FEMA is
working closely with dr. Burks and the
distributors to pray or to supply of
resources where they are most needed
we're finding the location that they
have to they have to get to that
location we have locations that are very
important to get to and get to them fast
and that's where they're going so we
have a very strong priority this
pandemic has reaffirmed the importance
of keeping vital supply chains at home
we cannot outsource our independence we
cannot be reliant or in foreign
I've been saying this for a long time if
we've learned one thing it's let's do it
here let's build it here let's make it
here we've got the greatest country in
the world we gotta start bringing our
supply chains back somebody years ago
got this crazy idea let's build all over
the place and let's have parts let's
have a screw for a car delivered and
made in a country that's far I would
have liked Trump's own idea where all of
his products for his various failed
businesses came from China and other
countries his idea I guess it was a bad
one he says and I like making it right
here in the USA and I think we've
learned a lot about that and especially
maybe when it comes to pharmaceutical
products we've also conducted major
military operations providing cities and
states with additional medical capacity
and the incredible 1,800 men and women
from the Army Corps of Engineers you
just met with Todd he's the job they've
done is incredible but we have nurses
doctors we have experts in every field
all over spoke with Governor Cuomo spoke
with Mayor DeBlasio spoke with many of
the other governor's that I'm both
friendly and D I think I'm friendly with
just about all of them if you can
believe it great Freddie currently with
a lot of them I've gained a lot of
respect for a lot of the governor's both
Republican and Democrat during this
process some really good people some
really good talent but we're sending a
lot of our medical people not only are
construction people like Todd semaa
night but a lot of our medical people
are being sent all over the country to
different locations New York City New
York State and New Jersey I spoke with
Phil today's doing a terrific job in New
Jersey but New Jersey got hit very very
hard filmography governor from today
this crisis began America launched a
scientific mobilization of colossal size
and scale someday they'll be able to
write the true story because nobody's
seen anything like it the fake news just
refuses to cover a year ago but that's
okay but the people are understanding
and that's what matters to me there are
now 72 active trials underway
across the United States researching
dozens of therapies and treatments and
another 211 are in the planning stages
they're getting I mean they're literally
mobilizing on therapeutics and also on
vaccines a tremendous progress is being
made on vaccines and I must say on
therapeutics I mean frankly if I had my
choice give me the therapeutics right
now because that would every day he says
huge progress is being made on vaccines
it's like as much progress is being made
on something that will take a year is
you can make in a day right things that
look like they could be an answer but
we'll know soon being tested working out
right now this includes their therapies
designed to attack the virus as well as
others that would hinder its replication
reduce the rate of infection control the
immune response or transfer life-saving
antibodies from the blood of recovered
patients and one of the incredible
things that we've seen and Mike and I
were talking about it before is the fact
oftentimes somebody gets very ill from
the plague okay from this horrible
scourge and they get better and they
recover the first thing they say is I
want to give my blood that's happened
the doctors have told me it's happened
so much I want to give my blood I want
to give my blood notice he hasn't been
mentioning hydroxi for a few days
because it hasn't been looking good for
a while over the weeks I think we'll be
talking about it in the not-too-distant
future
Johnson and Johnson's very well along on
vaccines again the vaccines have to be
tested that therapeutics are for now but
a lot of good things are happening on
both but ultimately we also hope to
prevent infection to a safe very safe
vaccine and that'll be a great thing
when we have that and we will have that
so with that I'd like to introduce ad
Magua and Brad Smith to discuss some of
the incredible things that have been
done and we have they really are what
they've been able to do at a very very
short period of time with and equipment
you're going to see equipment that you
haven't seen before right and if you
just come up Brad if you guys would come
up
could give us a little display of some
of the equipment that we have and show
us some other things that are happening
having to do with testing because
testing is a big word remember it was
all ventilators oh and the reason was
all very bland I thought he was bringing
up a new person
some guy guar like GWA are the metal
band or whatever he's talking about
Admiral sure are right now I of course
we know him
send them anyway of thousands being made
a week and they're very high quality and
that wasn't playing well so then they
said testing testing uh we'll get them
on testing what testing is much easier
than ventilated ventilators are big
machines that are very complex that are
expensive you need real real you need a
group of people that really know what
they're doing we took auto line so we
took a lot of different people and now
we've done that but it used to be
ventilators ventilators ventilators now
it's testing testing testing and I think
the Admiral and I think that bread will
show you some things that you haven't
seen that are really very spectacular
having to do with testing we're way
advanced way advanced the list I showed
you these are places you can go if
you're in the States 5,000 different
machines five thousand they're all over
the country we have international also
but what is the role of other country
but you'll see something now that's
really I popping in terms of what
they've done and they've done this under
great pressure they've come up with
things under great pressure that are
absolutely amazing so please if you
would hi guy the way I am seeing the
memberships come in and I'll thank
everybody for the website memberships
when we have a pause president I want to
talk about a couple things today a
little bit different than I've spoken
about before since early March we've
really been focusing on two key concepts
for testing number one to assure and
expand supplies in the US market this is
really critical because we were talking
about really a cottage industry with
very minimal suppliers that we were
asking to supply over a two-week period
of time the normal production that would
be for at least a year
and as simple as a swab is a swab is not
a swab is not a swab and we need to be
very careful that when we put something
in a person and tell them a test result
that it's really correct the second
component is to secure sufficient
supplies at FEMA during this time of
peak disease where we could alleviate
any mal distributions within the state
this is the FEMA process of requesting
and sending things out and also
supporting outbreaks
so starting many weeks ago starting in
my office many weeks ago we assembled a
multidisciplinary team of really
incredible people the medical side of
the equation which I represent the
laboratory side of the equation
high-tech side of the equation logistics
and operation and Brad Smith is is his
day job this director of the Center for
Medicare and Medicaid Services an
incredibly important component of our
country's CMS system building the future
health care system but has done in a
really incredible job operationally and
logistically in bringing everyone
together we have focused on every piece
of the supply chain that relates to
testing down to the most minut detail
and he's gonna talk to you about some of
that but that started in the second week
of March with starting an airlift
because the only supplier the main
supplier of swabs at that time was a
place in Italy that was completely shut
off because of the outbreak in Italy so
Admiral upchuck arranged great al Air
Force planes to go to Italy to bring
millions of swabs back to secure that's
just how it started and it's expanded
since then the second part is we've been
really Matt marrying and this has been
the beauty the logistics and supplies to
the overall strategy two pieces of
strategy number one what is the overall
testing strategy and dr. Burks has had
just an elegant strategy in the past but
even more important in the future when
we make sure we take care of indigent
populations and those most vulnerable so
the clinical the contact tracing and the
monitoring of those were at most risk
we've also married it to the strategy
and you've heard more than you know
about okay wanted to know about it that
a small machine this point of care is
good for certain things but it's not
going to test 5,000 people over a short
period of time
so the small machines the medium
machines and the large machines and how
to contextualise them and the third
thing before I give it to Brad which is
very important and its really critical
is coordinating the research the
epidemiology and the FDA regulatory
process and why is that so important
when we started five weeks ago if we
wanted to test this many people with the
technology we had we would have used
about 80% of the strategic national
stockpile in PPE just to do testing we
needed an innovation that innovation was
to be able to test out of the anterior
nose with a completely different kind of
swab it sounds very mundane but if you
don't do that you can't get the testing
to scale that allowed us to really go to
widespread testing last week moving to
polyester swabs which is going to open
up millions of new swabs onto the market
but that's a regulatory science and
innovation step that had to co-occur
with this and with that I'm gonna let
Brad talk about yeah just a reminder
guys I hope all this is true but looking
at tests per day ANCOVA tracking dot-com
you see that the numbers are not really
increasing much at all over the last
several weeks this is just the data this
is just the numbers okay back to it past
several weeks to help increase the
supply of testing across the United
States as you all know there's really
three parts that you need to make the
test work first you need the machine
which is dr. Burks we'll share more and
the president spoke to we have a very
very large number of those across the
United States it's about making sure
that we're taking advantage of them the
second part of the testing is making
sure that we have the collection
supplies to actually be able to collect
the specimen and I'll talk a little bit
more about that and then the third part
is making sure that you have the
materials you need to support the
machine to ensure that you can actually
process the test once it gets to the lab
I'll let dr. Burks talk more about the
machines here in a second but as you'll
as you'll see across the United States
we have a tremendous number they range
in variety so we have some very small
machines that do point-of-care testing
they may do say 50 to 100 tests a day we
also have other very large machines they
can do several thousand
several thousand tests today on the
collection supply piece I'll talk
through a couple different kinds of
collection that can be done so for the
nucleic acid test which are the tests
that are currently being done today you
generally need a swab of the nose to do
that you need the swab you need the
collection tube and you also need the
transport media that it can be
transported in we have a large very
large number of swabs already in the
country but we have secured an
additional 30 million in production that
will be ramping up over the next several
weeks one company located in the
Northeast we're going to be using title
three of the DPA to help them build for
new production lines they are currently
the largest swab producer in the country
and this will help them ramp up their
production tremendously to over 20
million additional swabs a month a
second company located in Ohio is
currently the largest q-tip maker in the
country we're helping them convert their
line for making q-tips into making swabs
they are actually ramping up production
starting this week of swabs and we'll be
ramping up to over 10 million production
ten million per month so in total that's
over 30 million new swabs it will be
coming just over the next handful of
weeks the second piece is on the
collection tubes the collection tubes
we've been partnered with Oak Ridge
National Lab a Department of Energy Lab
based in Tennessee they have very unique
and sophisticated invest in jek ssin
molding manufacturing capability and
they are in the process of ramping that
up to create collection tubes and they
will be ramping up to over 40 million
collection tubes a month here over the
next several weeks in addition to the
swabs we believe that as testing
progresses there'll be other types of
testing like syrup serological testing
that will occur and those samples have
to be collected in different ways so
many times some of those tests will
require a finger prick so in addition
we've secured over 17 million lancets
which is what you use for the finger
prick so that we have those available as
well as 17 million alcohol swabs was
just what you need to clean the finger
before you do the finger prick in
addition although folks are not talking
about this much yet we also believe that
businesses across the country may want
thermometers to test folks as they come
into the
office and so we've secured over 650,000
infrared thermometers that states and
businesses will be able to access to be
able to test folks as they come in to
work so I think we've made tremendous
progress
on the collection side in addition to
the collection side we've been very
focused on ensuring that the labs have
what they need to process a a specimen
in a lab you really need two things you
need something called an extraction kit
and he needs something called a PCR test
in order to be able to fully process a
test you need both of these things
sometimes these things come together and
sometimes they come separate for some of
our point-of-care tests including the
abbot and Cepheid tests they come
together they are ramping up production
rapidly to over three million of those
tests per month and these are tests that
did not exist even a month ago the
second piece is on some of these large
machines they also sell complex cottages
that come together one of the big
manufacturers is that has already ramped
up production from about one point six a
month to more than twice that already
and that's already occurred in addition
to when they come together they also
sometimes come separate and we see
significant ramping up or production
there from our manufacturers through our
public-private partnerships and we're
seeing both several million more over
the next few weeks of both the RNA
extraction kit as well as the PCR test
kit so with that thank you alright well
there you go oh now we're about to mute
I thank you mr. president and I share
your admiration for this remarkable team
from the Army Corps of Engineers - -
Brad - animals are all there doing a
remarkable job every day as president
mentioned and today we had our weekly
conference call with gunner so we're
gonna be muting as I said this is just
the completely worthless part of it so
let me do a few things just so I get
caught up huge thank you to Lonnie Kratz
who is new member number 26 today at
join pakman.com Thank You Lonnie also
thanks - I think I thanked Lucinda
Hanson already but if I didn't Lucinda
thank you for your support I got a
request from Jacob to say can you say hi
to my mom Patricia
she watches fox news every morning not
good I balance it with you in the
afternoon
very good Patricia Jacob you have raised
a great kid
Jacob knows exactly what is and is not
disinformation and I would take a page
out of Jacobs notebook here beautiful
beautiful thing to do
also Dennis saying hi to Patricia
despite not being me which is absolutely
and completely fine I want to remind
everybody we will be having another
david pakman show chess tournament
tournament either late this week or next
week of course all of our viewers on
Twitch will be not just invited but
encouraged to participate I want to say
thanks to ghosts noted 24 who has
subscribed for five months five months
with prime and asks me what's my
favorite GWAR song I don't actually know
of any songs by guar also want to say
thank you to more sushi who has
subscribed with prime and I really truly
so much appreciate that Kaylin Brooks
asked hey David when did the u.s.
officially know it might be a pandemic
like Ovid and is it true it was as early
as the end of Obama's term I have no
evidence of that at this point in time
whatsoever incredible TV says I Bigley
enjoy your show Remender thank you very
much I appreciate that I also want to
say thanks to Kimberly Rae Kendrick
Kimberly Rae Kendrick is new member
number 27 today thank you so much
Kimberly I so appreciate your support
and that of everybody who's been
watching a few things to point you to as
we wait for Mike Pence to wrap up his
daily propaganda and we get hopefully
back soon to actual doctors speaking or
questions nasty questions we have a new
clip out about a doctor foul Qi brutally
schooling doc of not dr. Burks bouchy
I'd love to see that doctor foul he
brutally schooling Fox News propagandist
Laura Ingraham you can see that on my
youtube channel right now also a clip
about 35 seconds of absolutely
meaningless incomprehensible dribble
drivel from Donald Trump no dribbling I
have that
Michael Jordan documentary on my mind
drivel from Donald Trump from the Friday
press conference or maybe Saturday which
I believe is beyond English language
comprehension if you check it out
let me know what you think all of those
clips are already out on my youtube
channel
Brian Harvard asks Star Trek or Star
Wars it's Star Wars for me I know
nothing about Star Trek I've seen like
one of the new Star Trek movies with
young Captain Kirk and the other dude
playing you know this guy and I don't
know anything about Star Trek so for me
it's Star Wars all the way year of the
cat says you should compare the press
conferences that the Australian Prime
Minister does he can actually put
coherent sentences together yeah I've
read I've seen a little bit in red that
those are very very good Daniel Rivera
asks MJ or LeBron so as a person
probably LeBron it seems that Michael
Jordan's treatment of women and gambling
issues are not the best but as a player
absolutely Michael Jordan I grew up in
the Jordan era loved every minute of
watching the Chicago Bulls win six
during the 1990s I look forward to
watching the documentary very very soon
I want to say thank you also to Tyrone
Thompson Tyrone is new member number 28
today at join pakman.com and also a
terrific person William Armstrong is new
member number 29 if you're just joining
us nothing is wrong we have just made as
a group we've made the decision that
Mike Pence adds nothing each day and
merely propagandize --is as Trump looks
orange sweaty and swivels at the hips as
you can see a very very intense zoom
taking place there on Donald Trump a
scary moment for many many of us NK
crisp asks better call Saul or Breaking
Bad I love better call Saul but better
call Saul is good in part because of
Breaking Bad so it's got to be breaking
bad for me but better call Saul
tremendous I'm caught up on season five
which is airing right now
excellent show I mean just a fantastic
fantastic
gram but no I do believe that Breaking
Bad is even that much better even that
much better
let me go back and answer a couple of
other super chats here let's see here
Safra geum's has talked about the USA
knowing about co vid since november of
2019 anthony lows a go says this guy
gives me the creeps
i think you were talking about that
first general Semin it--or admiral
general yeah he was he was an
interesting guy
a merry allen says I hope a reporter
asks him about Cuomo's comments last
week I don't know that I would expect
that and if they do he certainly is not
going to answer that we very much know
Trump doesn't answer questions that he
does not like angel Arriaga has
subscribed on YouTube at the SOI boy
level and I very very much appreciate
that let's see if Mike Pence is winding
down here we are delivering a
whole-of-government approach for our
states as they as they deal with the
corona virus out no it's still
propaganda so let me update you again on
the testing numbers this increasingly is
the most important these are some of the
most important numbers daily which is
how many tests are we doing this page
Kovan tracking dot-com / data / - daily
okay will tell you that Trump just lied
trump says from week to week we doubled
our testing capacity if we roughly look
at the last seven days you will see that
we are right around 150,000 tests a day
if you look at the seven days before
that you see that we were roughly around
150,000 tests a day the capacity clearly
did not double over the last week so
regularly lying about testing
we must get to 500,000 tests a day
minimum to even have a conversation
about reopening we probably need a
million tests a day one model says we
need five million tests a day another
roadmap says we need 22 million tests
today a hundred and fifty thousand a day
won't cut it
capacity didn't double over the last
week from the previous week it simply
did not
it is a lie let's go back to the
doctor's president mr. president we just
want to show you a couple of additional
slides but also to remind all of
Americans that we still have the way I
feel much better having not listened
depends it's both in the Boston area and
across Massachusetts in Chicago to
really that our hearts go out to those
cities as they continue to struggle with
coronavirus and the consequences at the
hospitalization to all the health care
providers that are on the front lines we
wanted so these are the just an
illustration of the different types of
equipment that are out there describing
them both is low speed but it's just
propaganda what we need are test numbers
pictures of what the tests look like
less relevant we've got to be doing more
testing where we've been stagnant for
two and a half weeks Pittman ranged from
those different than that's why there's
5000 of them as noted by the president
in this list we wanted every governor
and every state and health laboratory
director to have a clear understanding
of the full capacity within the state
both for the capacity but also where
technical assistance and additional
supplies may be available and we were
proud to put the federal labs on that
list because the military and the VA has
stepped up every what step of the way to
provide support both in testing and care
and we have merit many military members
on the front lines and I'm sure the
military would offer their facilities to
the governor of Maryland or any governor
who wanted to utilize those to expand
testing so the next slide I'm just gonna
run through them very quickly so every
governor not only received the Excel
spreadsheet with the complete list of
the equipment and the zip code of the
location in the laboratory to really be
able to create a mosaic of laboratories
of the high speed and low speed
equipment together to meet the needs of
their clients depending if they're
drive-through or Hospital needs so this
is what Florida looks like next slide
this is what Louisiana looks like next
slide Maryland with significant capacity
next slide Virginia with significant
capacity throughout the state next slide
New York obviously a lot of capacity in
New York City
with overlapping capacity it's important
to know where this is because then the
hospitals and labs can support each
other when they need search I'm going to
pick up one of the Abbott tests soon
this is New Jersey
next slide Pennsylvania next slice
Massachusetts next slide
Ohio next slide Oklahoma okay I mean I
think we got it Washington State's
Wyoming so we wanted to show both in
states that have large populations and
in states that have lower populations
you can see right the good question
people are asking like what exactly do
we learn about capacity from this when
the numbers don't move the Walter Reid
group in the American Society of
microbiologists and all the lab
directors to really create a web of
understanding of what the capacity is
currently what the capacity can be and
how the federal government can support
them in developing their strategies
linked to the overarching federal
strategy of testing as outlined in our
guidelines Thank You mr. president
University of Southern California in the
LA County Public Health put out a report
today that suggests that the penetrance
and the virus is as much as almost 40
times but it's not equally as many it's
great for ninety 42,000 people in LA
County may have been affected which
suggests two things it suggests that you
have a lot more people out there who
could be spreading the virus but it also
suggests that the case fatality rate is
more in line with the 2017-2018 flu than
what we've seen in some other areas of
the world but I'm wondering if you've
seen that what your thoughts were so
we're looking at all those studies very
carefully and I think you will remember
over the last three weeks I've been
talking about the level of asymptomatic
spread and my concern about asymptomatic
spread because with flu and other
diseases when people are sick it's easy
to contact trace when people are not
sick and shedding virus you have to have
a very different approach a very
different sentinel surveillance approach
of sentinel monitoring approach which we
outlined in the guidelines and it's why
the guidelines took that very seriously
we knew that was unique for respiratory
diseases
but it was because we were very
concerned about the level of
asymptomatic and if you remember we used
to we talked about younger age groups
may have more asymptomatic disease and
your asymptomatic disease may decrease
with respect the question is does she
buy that there could be a 40 X infection
rate or not groups this is still our
working hypothesis we have no data right
now still to support that but it's these
kinds of studies that help that we know
that New York and Detroit and other
cities are very interested which we want
to also support them in testing for
frontline responders first responders
and healthcare workers because we think
their exposure may have been the
greatest what we don't want to do and
I'm just gonna do another 30 seconds on
testing these tests are not a hundred
percent okay she didn't address the
study though diffic and I'm gonna go
over this over and over again so if you
have one percent of your population
infected and you have a test that's only
99 percent specific that means that when
you find a positive 50 percent of the
time will be a real positive and 50
percent of the time it won't be and
that's why we're really asking people to
start testing in among the first
responders and the health care workers
and it may have had the greatest
exposure because that's where the test
will be most reliable and then when we
have the luxury we can go out to broader
and broader communities but this has
been the fundamental question to begin
with and has been persistent and we will
emphasize the American people again this
is a highly contagious virus and we
don't know by looking at someone whether
they have pre-existing conditions or not
and so all of us as far as protecting
others must continue to do all of the
recommendations to ensure that when we
are in an asymptomatic state we're not
passing the virus to others well the
governor of South Carolina
today they're going to open some stores
with restrictions but they just told my
colleague Natasha Chen that they have
not achieved that criteria in the White
House guidelines about the downward
trajectory for 14 days
so should they not be reopening stores
today we have asked every governor to
follow the guidelines just as we've
asked every American to follow the other
not put out by the president but each of
the governors can decide for themselves
whether they've reached specific
guidelines in specific areas I had a
question I think on Saturday about
Jacksonville and their beaches so I did
spend about five hours going to every
state website and I will tell you that
the Florida Department of Health website
is extraordinary and this is what every
Department of Health should have because
when you go to that website you can see
that most of the cases are in southern
Florida in the miami-fort Lauderdale
Broward County area and if you look in
Jacksonville they had less than 20 cases
per day and less than 800 in four weeks
and so these are the kinds when you
inform the public and give them the
information that they need then they can
make decisions a lot of you saying well
actually even without meeting we're
saying you've got it you really should
meet the guidelines but here's a whole
bunch of ways to justify opening without
actually meeting them seen it myself but
I know from Jacksonville that they had
less than 20 cases a day and so this is
how we need to start informing our
community these web sites are critical
it's by zip code and it's by county they
can see cases they can see cumulative
cases they can see new cases they can
see hospitalizations they can see
mortality they can see age groups of
mentality and they can see where every
testing piece is this is how we have to
inform the American public and this is
where the American public will develop
confidence in each of their counties and
local governments
there's enough testing capacity right
now to proceed to face one but what
about phase two or phase three is there
are there enough machines are enough
cartridges are there enough regions not
enough go to a sort of apology lenses
visioning taking place over the next
month or two so you can see the current
machine outline and you can see that
both of these gentlemen have prepared to
have everything ready for Phase two and
preparing it now for what we will need
in the future and I see is a fantasy the
testing is not actually increasing
telling us how many machines have been
manufactured is very different than
having capacity and anyone can look at
the official testing numbers it's been
up and down in the same range for weeks
at this point this is not true I would
just agree with dr. Burks completely we
are ready right now to enter phase one
and we are ramping up all our
capabilities across the board not just
to achieve what's necessary for Phase
two
but 2 X 3 X 4 X so that we will be
absolutely over prepared when the nation
is ready to go into those phases Wow
we're going maximum you understand there
some people don't want to do that's two
lies in one but we're going maximum
we're going to the outer limits and I
think that's the way probably it should
be Jeff good mr. president to return to
a topic that you opened the press
conference with oil u.s. crude futures
today went below zero when it's a
negative 10 negative yeah like interest
rates they go negative does that make
you want to see Saudi Arabia and Russia
and OPEC plus two more sure much of it
has to do with short sellers much of it
has to do if you look a month into the
future I think it's at 25 or 28 dollars
a barrel so a lot of people got caught
they got caught and there are a lot of
people that are not too happy because
they got caught so if you take a look at
it you'll see it's more of a financial
thing than an oil situation but because
you take I believe in a month or so in
other words go a little bit out it's at
25 and 28 dollars a barrel so it's
largely a financial squeeze and they did
get squeezed
however Saudi Arabia and other countries
make more than I've already done that
Saudi Arabia is cutting back Russia is
cutting back
Mexico is cutting back and the OPEC plus
they called OPEC plus additional states
are cutting back we know and you know
the problem is nobody's driving the car
anywhere in the world essentially 184
nations factories are closed and
businesses are closed and so all of a
sudden we had really a lot of energy to
start off with oil in particular and a
lot and then all of a sudden they lost
40 50 percent of their market so it just
stopped so it's going to be picking up
and the energy business will be strong
but they cut back it could be 20 million
barrels but it's let's say 15 and that
was between Russia and Saudi Arabia but
this had to do with the squeeze and it
was a very tough squeeze a lot of people
got more right now well they got to
Dubai the market to be honest look same
thing over here if the market is the way
it is people are gonna slow it down are
they gonna stop that's gonna be
automatic and that's happening yeah mr.
president on criminal justice reform in
these SBA loans I got an email early
this morning from a fella in the
northwest who owns a supply business and
he has a felony on his record nonviolent
felony in the past five years which
under SBA guidelines makes him
ineligible for one of these PPP loans so
he is now had to let go 50 employees
many of whom are criminals trying to get
back into society I don't believe
there's anything in the cares Act that
would restrict if you give me the name
his name I'll have that checked out yeah
I'll do that friend of yours no no
somebody who called you to say is a
criminal and Trump it's inconceivable
for Trump that somebody might care about
somebody who's not their friend
notice how amazing that was Trump's like
it must be a friend why else would
anybody do something for somebody you
don't know if these companies that open
and they have employees come back to
work and they get sick
well these companies be liable which
companies you talking about companies
manufacturing any kind of company
eventually where they get sick well I'll
give you an answer to that I'll give you
a legal answer to that when we're
looking up but we had tried to take
liability away from these companies we
just don't want that because we want the
companies to open and open some but I'll
get you a legal opinion on that
I'll get you well that's what I'm saying
I'll get you a legal opinion nobody's
discussing no but we will now have any
business executives have voiced concern
to you about that one it's not at this
point but we're gonna look because they
have talking about general liability
nobody's ever so I'll get you a specific
answer from the lawyers okay
when you were talking earlier you were
talking about the PPP deal deal and then
mentioned yes they are in the first
stimulus package even though you had
announced I think you know the price of
oil right there don't you I do do you
know they dollars of course nobody's
ever heard of negative oil before but
it's for a short term right in in your
opening remarks you were talking about
the PPP deal and then you mentioned the
75 million barrels of oil that you
previously the said you wanted to
you weren't able to get funding for that
in the first deal someone during our
yeah with the price you're talking about
you don't need funding they pay you see
that's true if you can get so my my
question my first question is are you
asking for funny at a minute no that
will let people store so will store it
will use it as storage and charge for it
but people need storage desperately and
we have my haven't gassed up my car and
I can't even remember one requirement of
the PPP interim finding deals if we
could buy it for nothing we're gonna
take everything we can get the only
thing I like better than that is where
they pay you to take the oil
I was just paid twelve hundred bucks to
store gasoline in my garage
I said sure why not be that but no we'd
like to have Congress this is a great
time to buy oil and we'd like to have
Congress approve it so that we could
instead of just storing it for the big
usually the big companies because I
think we have 75 million gallons right
now capacity that's a lot
it's we've been building it up over a
period of time yeah I some people
worried about my car I'm not literally
not driving I go to the grocery store
you know I'm doing minor things the car
is being driven don't worry I'm
exercising the gaskets together it will
be full okay please finish up we'll go
right yeah sometimes including senator
Kramer is calling you to stop Saudi oil
shipments
right now is that you can do that under
Section 232 is that something that you
would well look at it I heard just as
I'm walking into the room we certainly
have plenty of oil so I'll take a look
at that okay yes please first on on
testing the second on the SBA loan
program one will you or will you in fact
invoke the DPA to force that company you
mentioned to ramp up production uh well
we really don't need it we use it we go
up and I've used it a lot but we use it
as amber suggests which sometimes all
they have to do is see it coming do you
want to talk about that I think this is
I don't think any of us knew very much
about the DPA but they're sort of a four
side of the DPA where you force a
company to do something but there's a
second side of it which is really a hand
up the company we're talking about have
done has done everything to support this
effort and have ramped up production I'm
on the phone with them multiple times a
day this is the hand up this is the
government coming in and saying how can
we help you expand your lines
there's no asynchrony here at all so
this is the hand up side of the DPA
which is exactly what these small
American heroic companies need they
don't need to be forced they're all in
their employees are all in so today we
were on cider there were folks on site
with that company finishing out what
their capital projections will be in
order to be able to ramp up these
additional four lines that spoke about
the company will then turn in a white
paper to the DoD that will then help
move the process forward but it's
actively in process stand that the need
is enormous but on March 24 for March
21st the administration promised 27
million tests by the end of March so far
roughly four million people have been
tested so where are the other 23 nations
now handing out material on the pipeline
help us understand that discrepancy
so since I was the one who said that let
me explain where we are where we were so
I was getting my information was correct
information about the actual tests that
are in the marketplace so if you want to
use those metrics there's been over 40
million quote in the marketplace but we
have an end-to-end the issue that we
needed to deal with and that's what
we've been dealing with the swabs the
transport media if we don't have people
utilizing the machines so we're a month
late and 16 million tests short is it am
i doing the or was it wait what was the
number 27 some crazy number have a lot
of tests in the market and those are
correct numbers but if the machines
aren't utilizing them and they're not
organized at that level then they're not
being they're not being utilized to its
fullest you would you would have a lot
of those you imagine oh we've got 27
million tests we're just not using them
oh you guys were right all along
P that could be done if the machines
were utilized more following question
unbelievable per hour flourish I go for
our and the vice president just said
this mr. Smith said it that there will
be enough tests in place for phase 1
there are there are the question is
alive what's the standard of testing
that you now have the capability for is
it test people who are only very ill is
it test people who have the sniffles is
it just people who come in that's
because they want to get a testing me
what what is it standard here it is the
guidelines but I tried to be a little
specific about this on Friday and we all
try to number one is you need to test
everyone who's symptomatic right and you
need to over test them because we're
talking any symptoms that would be
consistent with kovat right they don't
have it so and there's a wide range of
citizen s them and you want to over test
and we talked about the approximate
metric with ambassador birx fully
supports because we you know this is a
good metric that you want to get about
one positive for every 10 tests then you
know you over sample second and this is
a really important part of the strategy
is because so many people are a symptom
at
there's no way that you can test enough
people to pull one asymptomatic out of
300 people in the population so the
strategy with ambassador birx offered
and you know I talked to epidemiologist
around the country and they go wow I
wish I would have thought of that is to
really focus on the vulnerable
population where we know that the ACE
and we bail rehab this could be much
higher than the rest of the population
and we are going to be focusing this is
what my office does and during normal
normal I want to be really clear if
you're feeling like maybe you're dumb
and I'm just being serious because
you're not getting this you're not dumb
they're incoherent about this they won't
tell us what is the number that we need
they say test doubled over the last week
the numbers show that they didn't the
the you're not dumb okay they're not
ready they don't have the capacity
they're not telling us the truth that
most of the models and people don't talk
about because that's where we're gonna
pick up the asymptomatic carrier and
when you do that that's when you focus
on track and trace if we have enough
tests right now for everyone to go into
Phase one why is the governor of
Maryland having to get half a million
tests from south-korea
correct I don't know what the governor
of Maryland is doing in South Korea but
there are calls an excess capacity every
day if he wanted to send 30 or 40,000
tests to LabCorp and quest that that
could be done that could be done
tomorrow that they needed to start to
take up their testing capacity and make
it adequate I think I think we're seeing
all across the country that in the
states that have been hardest hit their
capacity none of their capacity they're
testing far far exceed South Korea and
they've been able to do that on a
relatively straightforward issue isn't
whether they're exceeding South Korea
it's that they're buying tests from
South Korea look at this call today
like personally on this Oh
we spoke to Governor Hogan today I'll
follow up because they pull it once
nobody has an answer day that he had
acquired some tests from overseas maybe
we can put the slide back up the jab
but it's not over this is wrap no means
good question in the state of Maryland
and part of all show us dots on a map a
better place the order from South Korea
wouldn't wouldn't begrudge him or his
health officials for or the dentist but
that's the the capacity of all the
different laboratories and a number of
machines that are across Maryland's part
of what we were communicating today I
hope it's clear to everyone the
dishonesty and the misdirection on the
testing okay they won't tell us what
number they need they claim testing is
doubling when it's not everybody fails
so they abort and they get pence up
there and he says show them the dot
picture show them the dots private as
well as the doctors here but it's the
contact tracing piece we really believe
that states that meet the criteria of 14
days of of cases going down and proper
Hospital capacity
yeah they test people that have symptoms
and if they deploy resources to
vulnerable populations nursing homes and
other designated vulnerable populations
where we believe the threat of serious
outcomes from the corona virus is real
then we also today inform the governor's
that we will be deploying CDC teams to
every state and every territory in the
country to assist them in contact
tracing a governor jared Polis raised a
very good point about the legislation
the president is currently negotiating
on Capitol Hill he recommended that we
make sure that the new bill that has
some twenty five billion dollars in
testing resources also cover contact
tracing expenses by States we assured
him our administration strongly supports
that we communicated that to the
Secretary of the Treasury and the rest
of our negotiation team
we'll be pursuing that but we were able
to tell every one of the governor's that
we would be deploying teams we think of
10 or 12 for a start from CDC to reside
in all of our states and territories to
supervise and work with Connor the
question was about testing capacity I
mean it's such a depressing insane
situation with these tests keep a
careful eye and monitor your vulnerable
populations and when you come across a
case have a team on the ground that can
do the immediate contact tracing and
testing and that's how we that's how we
restrain and creating a spread of the
corona virus during phase one and
frankly it's the beginning of the
structure for how we contain the corona
virus going forward pointing is a
blunder but that's ok if they can't need
it to get a little knowledge would have
been helpful
the SBA loans do you think it's right
that major corporations major
institutions like the root spritz
restaurant chain like Harvard University
apparently got a lot of money under the
cares that money that was supposed to be
earmarked for small business owners do
you think that's fair I know one thing I
didn't get any that's for the truth'll I
didn't get any we'll look at individual
things and some people will have to
return it if we think it's inappropriate
he really changed that that money goes
to people who need it well it's being
done by great professionals it's being
done by banks and as you know community
banks all over the country there that's
what they do they loan money and they're
supposed to do it according to not only
criteria but according to what we think
is right but if somebody got something
that we think is inappropriate we'll get
it back ok good good point please
a different question about South Korea
there are reports that you are
personally negotiating with president
moon the terms of reduction of US forces
on the Korean Peninsula and that there
are four scenarios involved can you
confirm that and if so what is your
desired outcome well I think that South
Korea had a great talk with president
moon he's a friend of mine I
congratulate hit a wonderful election
victory I was very happy about that he
was as you know just recently know we
are negotiating for president moon and
for South Korea to help us monetarily
because we as you know we all right guys
as I said earlier we have a debate that
I'm moderating tonight it's not live
it's being recorded I'll tell you more
about it after it's done but I do have
to now wrap up the stream because this
is the only setup I have and I need this
setup in order to film that debate so I
will leave you here we'll pick it up
tomorrow clips all of that stuff and
I'll tell you more about the super
interesting debate coming up